The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PATRICK WINSTON: Well, I
suppose my first question
has to do with some remarks
that Tony made about Rod Brooks.
I remember Rod Brooks' work
for the one great idea he had,
which was the idea
of subsumption.
And the idea of
subsumption was to take
the notion of
procedural and data
abstraction from
ordinary programming
and elevate it to
a behavior level.
And the reason
for doing that was
that if you weren't working
so well at one level,
you would appeal
to another level
to get you out of trouble.
So that sounds like a
powerful idea to me.
And I'm just very interested
in what the panelists construe
to be the great
principles of robotics
that have emerged since then.
Are there great
principles that we
can talk about in a classroom
without just describing
how a particular robot works?
STEFANIE TELLEX:
So we were talking
about this ourselves
a little bit
and sort of asking ourselves
what makes a systems paper?
And what do you
write down in one
of those papers as
these general principles
that you extract from
building a system?
Because it seems like
there's two kinds of papers
in robotics-- the systems
paper, where you said,
I built this thing and
here's kind of how it works.
Where it's hard to extract,
I think, general principles
from that.
It's like, I built
this and this and this,
and this is what it did.
Here's a video.
But it does something
amazing, so it's cool.
And then there's, like, kind
of algorithm papers, which
tend to get more citations
and I don't know.
And they usually
work because they
have this chunk of knowledge,
subsumption architectures,
RRT Star's one of my
favorite examples.
It's the kind of paper,
there's an algorithm,
and then there's math that
shows how the algorithm works,
some results that they show.
And there's this nugget that
transfers from your brain--
to the author's
brain to your brain.
And I think it's hard to
know what that nugget is when
you've built a giant system.
One of the things that I've
been thinking about that
might be what that
might look like
is kind of design
patterns for robots.
This is a concept from
software engineering.
It's at a higher level
abstraction than a library
or something that you share,
but it's things about the ways
that you put software together.
So if you're a
hacker, you probably
heard of some of these patterns
like singleton and facade
and strategy.
They have these sort of
evocative names from this book,
Gang of Four is the nickname.
And I think there's a set of
design patterns for robotics
that we are slowly discovering.
So when I was hanging out
in Seth Teller and Nick
Roy's for my post-doc, there
was one that I really got
in my head, which was
this idea of pub/sub--
publish and subscribe.
You're talking about
YARP and LCM and Russ.
They all had this
idea that you don't
want to write a function to
call to get the autodetection
results.
You just want you detector
blasting out the results
as fast as it can all
the time, and then break
that abstraction.
And you get a lot of robustness
in exchange for that.
I think that's a design
pattern for robots.
I think there's probably
about 30 more of them.
And I bet Russ
knows a lot of them.
And Albert and Ed-- there's
people who know them maybe,
but they're not written down.
I think one thing I'd like to
do is write some more of them
down.
Sorry I didn't.
PATRICK WINSTON: Russ,
what do you think?
Your talk seemed to focus on
optimization as the answer.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's
a framework that I
think you can guess a lot of the
problems and get clear results.
I think looking across you can
point to clearer sort of ideas
that worked very well.
So I think for estimation
Bayes Rule works really well.
And you know, Monte
Carlo estimation
has worked really
well for planning
in high dimensional spaces.
Somehow randomization
was a magical bullet
where people start doing
RRT-type things as well
as trajectory
optimization-type things.
I do think that the open
source movement and the ability
to write software and
components and modules
has been a huge, huge thing.
And I do think that at the
low-level control level
is optimization-based
controllers
have been a magical thing.
I think any one of these--
in any one of these
sub-disciplines,
you can point to a
few real go-ahead
ideas that have
rocked our world,
and everybody gets behind them.
You know, I think maybe
the biggest one of all,
actually, has been LIDAR.
And then the ability--
I think sensing has really come
online and been so enabling
in the last few years that
I think if you look back
at the last 15, 20
years of robotics,
the biggest point
changes I think
has been with the sensors--
sensors upped their frame rate
resolution, gave depth.
When LIDAR and Kinect came out,
those just changed everything.
PATRICK WINSTON: Before we
leave the subject of Brooks
and subsumption, Tony,
you brought it up,
and there was a little
exchange between you
and Russ about why
it might be useful.
I noted that both Russ and
John talked about two--
one respect-- one
each major blunders
that their machines made.
Do you construe that
any of Brooks's stuff
might have been
useful in avoiding
those kinds of blunders?
TONY PRESCOTT: Potentially.
But I think these are really
challenging things that we're
trying to do with these robots.
So the biomimetic approach
that I take, I think,
is partly I want to mine
biology for insights
about how to solve problems.
And the problems
that we're realizing
are hard in robotics
are the problems that
are hard in biology as well.
So I think we
underestimated the problem
of manipulating objects.
But if you look in biology,
what other species apart from us
has really solved that problem
to the level of dexterity?
An octopus trunk, maybe but--
sorry, elephant trunk.
So I think that these
challenges take a--
prove to be much more
difficult than we might think.
And then other things
that intuitively seem hard
are actually quite easy.
So the path that we're taking in
some of our biomimetic robots,
like the MiRo robot toy is to
do stuff which actually people
think looks hard, but it's
relatively easy to do,
and these are solvable problems.
And then we can progress towards
what are obviously the harder
problems, and where
the brain has dedicated
a lot of processing power.
And I think object manipulation,
if you look in the brain,
is massive representation
for the hand.
And there's all these extra
motor systems in cortex that
aren't there in non-mammals.
And even in simpler mammals
they don't have motor cortex.
We've developed all
these extra motor
cortical areas, direct
corticospinal projections.
All of this is dedicated to
the manipulation problem.
So I think we're finding out
what the hard problems are
by trying to build the robots.
And then we can maybe find
out what the solutions
are by looking at the biology.
Because in that case,
particularly, you
have low level systems for--
that can do grasp, and
that are there in reptiles.
And then you have these
additional systems in mammals,
and particularly
in primates, that
can override the
low-level systems to do
dexterous control.
PATRICK WINSTON: John,
you look like you're
eager to say something.
JOHN LEONARD: I just want
to talk about subsumption,
because it had such a
huge effect on my life
as a grad student.
It was sort of like
the big thing in 1990
when I was finishing up.
But I really developed
a strong aversion to it,
and so I tried to argue with
Rod back then, but not very
successfully.
I would say, when will
you build a robot that
knows its position?
And he would say, I
don't know my position.
But I think some of the
biological evidence,
like the grid cells
and things that maybe
at an autonomic
subconscious level
there is sort of position
information in the brain.
But subsumption,
I think, as a way
of trying to strive
for robustness where
you build on layers,
that's a great inspiration.
But I feel that the intelligence
without representation
sort of work that Rod
did, I just don't buy it.
I think we need representation.
PATRICK WINSTON: I guess
there are two separable ideas.
JOHN LEONARD: Yes.
PATRICK WINSTON: The
no representation idea
and the layering idea.
JOHN LEONARD: Yeah.
I like the layering,
and I'm less
keen on the no representation.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I'm
curious if Giorgio--
I mean, you showed
complicated system diagrams.
And you're obviously doing
very complicated tasks
with a very complicated robot.
Do you think-- do you see
subsumption when you look
at those--
GIORGIO METTA: Well,
it's actually there.
I don't have time to
enter into the details.
But the way it's
implemented, ER,
allows you to do
subsumption or other things.
There's a way to
physically take the modules
and, without
modifying the modules,
connect them through scripts
that can insert logic
on each module to sort of
preprocess the messages
and decide whether to subsume
one of the module or not,
or activate the
various behaviors.
So in practice, can be a
subsumption architecture,
a purer one or whatever other
combination you have in mind
for the particular task.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Maybe a
slightly different question
is did the subsumption
view of the world
shape the way you
designed your system?
GIORGIO METTA: It may have
happened without knowing,
because that piece of software
started at MIT while I
was working with Rod.
But we didn't try to build
the subsumption architecture
in that specific case.
But the style, maybe of
the publish-subscribe
that we ended up
doing was derived
from subsumption in a sense.
Was in spirit, although
not in the software itself.
But going back to whether
there's a clear message that we
can take, certainly
I will subscribe
to Stefanie message of the
recyclable software, the fact
that we can now
build these modules
and build large architectures.
This allows doing experiments
that we never dreamed
of until a few years ago.
So we can connect many
powerful computers
and run vision and
control optimisation
very efficiently, and especially
if recycling the software.
So you don't have to implement
inverse kinematics everyday.
PATRICK WINSTON: Well, I
think the casual observer
this afternoon, one
good example being me,
would get the sense that,
with the exception of Tony,
the other four of you are
interested in the behavior,
but not necessarily interested
in understanding the biology.
Is that a misimpression
or is that correct?
And when you mention LIDAR,
for example, that's something
I don't think I use.
And it's doing something--
it's enabling a robot
with a mechanism
that is not biological.
So to what degree are any of
you interested in understanding
the nature of
biological computation?
JOHN LEONARD: I care
deeply about it.
I just don't feel I have
the tools or the bandwidth
to really dive into it.
But every time I talk to Matt
Wilson I leave feeling in awe,
like I wish I could clone myself
and hang out across the street.
GIORGIO METTA: Well--
Yeah.
Go ahead.
STEFANIE TELLEX: I get it.
I kind of feel the same.
I mean, I'm an engineer.
I'm a hacker.
I build things.
And I think that's
the way that I
can make the most progress
towards understanding
intelligence is by
trying to build things.
But every time I talk
to Josh, you know,
I learn something new,
and Noah and Vikash.
PATRICK WINSTON: Say that again?
STEFANIE TELLEX: Every time I
talk to Josh and Noah Goodman
and Bertram Malle, people from
the psychology and cognitive
science [INAUDIBLE],,
I learn something
and I take things away.
But I don't get excited about
trying to build a faithful
model that incorporates
everything that we know about
the brain, because
I just don't--
I can't put all
that in my brain.
And I feel that I'm better
guided by my engineering
intuition and the
things that I've
learned by trying
to build systems
and seeing how that plays out.
PATRICK WINSTON: On
the other hand, Tony,
you are interested in biology
and you do build stuff.
TONY PRESCOTT: Yeah.
I'm interested in it,
because I trained originally
a psychologist.
So I came into robotics in
order to build physical models.
PATRICK WINSTON: So
why do you build stuff?
TONY PRESCOTT: Because I think
the theory is the machine.
Our theories and
psychology and neuroscience
are never going to be like
theories are in physics.
We're not going to be
able to express them
concisely and convince people
of them in a short paper.
We're going to be able
to, though, build them
into machines like
robots and show people
that they do behavior,
and hopefully
convince people that way that
we have a complete theory.
PATRICK WINSTON: So it's
a demonstration purpose?
Or a convincing purpose?
TONY PRESCOTT: It's
partly to demonstrate
the sufficiency of the theory.
I think that's the big reason.
But another motivation that
has grown more important for me
is to be able to ask
questions of biologists
that that wouldn't
occur to them.
Because I think the
engineering approach--
you're actually
building something--
raises a lot of
different questions.
And those are then
interesting questions
to pursue in biological studies
and questions that might not
occur to you otherwise.
So I go back to
Brightenburg's comment
that when you try to
understand a system,
there's a tendency to
overestimate its complexity,
and that when you
do synthesis that's
a whole lot different
from analysis.
And actually, with
the brain, we tend
to either underestimate or
overestimate its complexity
and we rarely get it right.
So the things that we
think are complex sometimes
turn out to be easy.
So an example would be
in our whisker system,
it's really quite easy to
measure texture with a whisker.
And there's lots of different
ways of doing that that work.
But intuitively you might
not have thought that.
But getting shape
out of whiskers
is harder, because
it's an integration
problem across
time, and you have
to track position and
all these other things.
So these things
turn out to be hard.
So I think trying to build
synthetic systems helps
us understand what are the
real challenges the brain has
to solve, and that's
interesting for me.
PATRICK WINSTON: Is there
an example of a question
that you didn't know is
there when you started?
TONY PRESCOTT: Yeah.
PATRICK WINSTON:
And you wouldn't
have found if you hadn't
attempted to build?
TONY PRESCOTT: So
when we started
trying to build
artificial whiskers,
the engineers that
were building the robot
said, well, how much power
does the motor have to have
that drives the whisker?
I mean, what happens when the
whisker touches something?
Does it continue to move and
bend against the surface?
Or does it stop?
And well, we said we'll look
that up in the literature.
And of course, there
wasn't an experiment
that answered that question.
So at that point we said, OK,
we'll get a high speed camera
and we'll start watching rats.
And we found that when
the whiskers touch,
they stopped moving
very quickly.
So they make a light touch.
And intuitively, yeah, maybe--
because we make a light touch.
Obviously, we don't bash
our hands against surfaces.
But it's not
obvious, necessarily,
when you have a flexible sensor
that that's what you would do.
And in some
circumstances, the rats
allow their whiskers to
bend against objects.
So understanding when you make
a light touch and when you bend
was really a question that
became important to us
after we'd started
thinking about how
to engineer the system.
How powerful do the
motors need to be?
PATRICK WINSTON: I'm very
sympathetic to that view,
being an engineer myself.
I always say if
you can't build it,
you don't really understand it.
TONY PRESCOTT: Yeah.
PATRICK WINSTON: So
many of you-- all of you
have talked about
impressive systems today.
And I wonder if any
of you would like
to comment on some problem
you didn't know that was there
and you wouldn't have
discovered if you
hadn't been building the kinds
of stuff that you have built.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's a long list.
I mean, I think we
learn a lot every day.
Let me be specific.
So with Atlas, we took a
robot to a level of maturity
that I've never taken before.
I see videos from companies
like Boston Dynamics
that are extremely impressive.
I think one of the things that
separates a company like that
from the results you
get in a research lab
is incredible amounts
of hours, sort
of a religion to data logging
and analysis, and sort
of finding corner cases,
logging them, addressing them,
incremental improvement.
And researchers
don't often do that.
And actually, I
think a theme that,
at least in a
couple of the talks,
was that maybe this is
actually a central requirement.
And in some sense,
our autonomy really
should be well
suited to doing that,
to maybe automatically
finding corner cases
and proving robustness
and all these things.
But the places that broke
our theory were weird.
I mean, so the stiction
in the joints of Atlas
is just dominant.
So we do torque
control, but we have
to send a feedforward velocity
signal to get over friction.
If we're started at zero
and we have to start moving,
if we don't send a
feedforward velocity signal,
our model is just
completely wrong.
When you're walking
on cinder blocks
and you go near the
ankle limit in pitch,
there's a strange coupling
between the mechanism
which causes the ankle to roll.
And it'll kick your robot
over just like that,
if you don't watch for it.
And we thought about
putting that into our model,
addressing it with
sophisticated things.
It's hard and ugly and gross.
And it's possible, but
we do things to just--
you know, Band-Aid
solution that.
And I think there's all this
stuff, all these details that
come in.
I think the theory
should address it all.
I think we did pretty well.
I'd say we got 80%
of the way there,
70%, 80% of the way there
with our theory this time.
And then we just decided
that there was a deadline
and we had to cover some
stuff up with band-aids.
But that's the good stuff.
That's the stuff we
should be focused on.
That's the stuff we should
be devoting our research
efforts on.
PATRICK WINSTON: If you were
to go into a log cabin today
and write a book on Atlas
and your work on it,
what fraction of that book
would be about corner cases
and which fraction would
be about principles?
RUSS TEDRAKE: We really stuck to
principles until last November.
That was our threshold.
November, we had to send
the robot back for upgrades.
We said, until then, we're
going to do research.
The code base is
going to be clean.
And then when we got the
robot back in January,
we did everything we needed
to to make the robot compete
in the challenge.
So I think 70% or 80% of
the way, we got there.
And that it was just
putting hours on the robot,
finding those screw cases.
And then, if I were to
write a book in five years,
I hope it would be--
PATRICK WINSTON: Is there a
principle on that ankle roll?
Or was that--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, absolutely.
We could have thrown
that into the model.
It just would have increased
the dimensionality.
It would have been
a non-linear term.
We could have done it,
we just didn't have time
to do it at the time.
And it was going to
be one of many things
we would have had to do if
we had taken the principle
approach throughout.
There's other things that
we couldn't have put nicely
into the model, that we
would have needed to address.
And that should be our agenda.
TONY PRESCOTT: If that
was your own robot,
would you have just
re-engineered the ankle
to make that problem
less of an issue?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It
wasn't about the ankle.
It was about the fact
that there's always
going to be something
unmodeled that's
going to come up and get you.
And with robots, I think
we're data starved.
We don't have the big data
problem in robotics yet.
And I think you're
limited by the hours you
can put on your robot.
We need to think about
how do you aggressively
search for the cases that
are going to get you?
How do you prove robustness
to unmodeled things?
I think this is fundamental.
It's not a theme I would
have prioritized if I hadn't
gotten this far with a robot.
PATRICK WINSTON: But Giorgio,
what about building iCub?
Were there big
problems that emerged
in the course of building
that you hadn't anticipated?
GIORGIO METTA:
Well first of all,
there's a problem of power.
I guess for Atlas
it's very different.
But for electric motors,
you're always short of space,
short of space where
to put the actuators.
And you start filling
the available-- if you
have a target size, you start
filling it very quickly.
And there's no room
for anything else.
And then you start sticking the
electronics wherever you can,
and cables and everything.
Certainly if-- I
mean, a difference
in design from the biological
actuators and the artificial
actuators to make
life very difficult.
And especially when you
have to go through something
like a hand, where
you like to have
a lot of degrees of freedom.
But there's no way you
could actually build it,
so you have to take
shortcuts here and there.
And I guess the same is
true, then, for computation.
And you resort to putting
as many micro-controllers
as you can inside the
robot, because you
want to have efficient
control loops.
And then you say, well,
maybe have a cable
for a proper image
processing because there's
no way you can squeeze
that into the robot itself.
It's not surprising.
It's just a matter of when
you're doing to design,
you soon discover that
there are limitations
you have to take into account.
I don't know whether
it is surprising.
I mean, I guess we
learn the lesson
across many years of design.
We designed other
robots before the iCub.
We sort of--
I thought we knew
where the limits where
with the current technology.
PATRICK WINSTON:
I wonder if the--
you say you learned
a lot building iCub.
I wonder if this
knowledge is accessible.
It's knowledge
that you discussed
in meetings and seminars,
and thought about at night
and fixed it the next day.
Is any of it--
if I wanted to build iCub
and couldn't talk to you,
would I have to
start from scratch?
I know you've got the stuff
on the web and whatnot, but--
GIORGIO METTA: Yeah.
That's probably enough for--
PATRICK WINSTON:
--reasons in them
GIORGIO METTA: Sorry?
PATRICK WINSTON: Your
web material has designs,
but it doesn't have reasons.
GIORGIO METTA: Yeah.
Yeah, that's-- that's right.
No, the other thing we
documented the process itself.
So that information,
I don't know,
resides in the people that
actually made the choices when
we were doing the design.
There's one other thing that
maybe is important, is that--
so the iCub is
about 5,000 parts.
And that's not
good, because there
are 5,000 parts that can break.
And that may be something
interesting for design
of materials for robots, or new
ways of building the robots.
And at the moment,
basically everything
that could potentially
break has happened,
that it failed on the
iCub over many years.
Even parts that theoretically
we didn't think could break,
well, they could.
But we estimated
maximum torques,
whatever, and then it happened.
Somebody did something silly
and we broke a shoulder.
It's a steel part
that we never thought
it could actually break.
And it completely failed.
I mean, those type of
things are maybe interesting
for future designs, or
for either simplifying
the number of parts or figuring
out ways of doing less parts
or, let's say, different
ways of actually building
the mechanics of the robot.
PATRICK WINSTON: I
suppose I bring it up
because some of us in
CSAIL are addressing--
not me, but some
people in CSAIL are
interested in how you
capture design rationale,
how you capture
those conversations,
those whiteboard sketches
and all of that sort of thing
so that the next generation can
learn by some mechanism other
than apprenticeship.
But let's see.
Where to go from here?
iCub is obviously
a major undertaking
and Russ had been
working like a slave
for three years on Atlas robot.
Do you-- I don't know
quite how to phrase this
without being too trumpish.
But the soldering
time to thinking time
must be very high on
projects like this.
Is that your sense?
Or do you think that the
building of these things
is actually essential to
working out the ideas?
Maybe that's not quite the
question I'm going to ask.
Maybe a sharper question
is given the high ratio
of soldering time
to thinking time,
is it something that
a student should do?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I'm lucky
that someone else built
the robot for us.
Giorgio has done much more
than we have in this regard.
PATRICK WINSTON: Well, by
soldering time you know--
RUSS TEDRAKE: I know.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
We--
PATRICK WINSTON:
It's a metaphor.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
but we got pretty far into
it with the good graces
of DARPA and Google
slash Boston Dynamics.
The software is where we've
invested our solder time.
A huge amount of software
engineering effort.
I spent countless
hours on setting up
build servers and stuff.
Am I stronger, you know,
am I better for it?
I think having invested, we
can do research very fast now.
So I'm in a new position
to be able to try
really complicated
ideas very quickly
because of that investment.
It was actually-- I
knew going in what
I was going to be doing.
I saw what John and
other people got out
of being in the Urban Challenge,
including in especially
the tools, like the LCM that
we've been talking about
and stuff today.
And I wanted that for my group.
So it was a very
conscious decision.
I'm at a place now that we
can do fantastic research.
Every one of the students
involved in great research work
on the project.
We hired a few staff
programmers to help with some
of the non-research stuff.
And I think the
hardware is important.
It's hard to balance, but
I do think it's important.
PATRICK WINSTON: Just one
short follow-up question there.
Earlier you said that
some of your students
didn't want to work on it.
And why was that?
Was that a principal reason?
RUSS TEDRAKE: People knew
how much soldering time there
was going to be.
Right?
And the people that had
their research agenda and it
was more theoretical,
and they didn't
want that soldering time.
Other people said, I'm
still looking for ideas.
This is going to motivate
me for my future work.
They jumped right in.
And super strong students made
different decisions on that.
PATRICK WINSTON: And they
both made the right decisions.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think so.
PATRICK WINSTON: Yeah.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
PATRICK WINSTON: But
John, you've also
been involved in-- well,
the just driving car thing
was a major DARPA
grand challenge.
Some people have been critical
of these grand challenges
because they say
that, well, they
drive the technology
up the closest hill,
but they don't get you
on a different hill.
Do you have any feelings
about these things,
if they're good
idea in retrospect,
having participated in them?
JOHN LEONARD: Let's see.
I'm really torn on
that one because I
see how the short term benefits
of the community-- and you
can point to things
like the Google car--
that there's a clear impact.
But DARPA does have a
mindset that once they've
done something, they
declare victory and move on.
So now if you work, say,
on legged locomotion, which
one of my junior
colleagues does,
DARPA won't answer his emails.
It's like, OK, we did
legged locomotion.
And so I think
that the challenge
is to be mindful of
where we are in terms
of the real long-term progress.
And it's not an
easy conversation
to have with the
funding agencies, but--
PATRICK WINSTON: But
what about a brand
new way of doing
something that is not
going to be competitive in terms
of demonstration for a while?
Is that a problem
that's amplified
by these DARPA grand challenges?
I mean, take chess, for example.
If you had a great idea
about how humans play chess,
you would never be
competitive with Deep Blue,
or not for a long time.
So you wouldn't be
in a DARPA program
that was aimed at doing chess.
So is that a--
do you see that as a problem?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think
it's a huge problem.
But I still see a
role for these kind
of competitions as benchmarks.
And I wouldn't do
another one today.
I mean, for me it
was the right time
to sort of see how
our theory had gotten,
try it on a much more
complicated robot, benchmark
where we are, get some
new ideas going forward.
It was perfect for me.
But you can't set
a research agenda.
JOHN LEONARD: And they're
dangerous for students.
So one of our strongest
students never
got his PhD, because his
wife is in program PhD
program in biology and he
did the DARPA challenge.
And she finished her thesis.
And he said, I don't want to
live alone on the east coast
while she starts her faculty
position in California.
So I'm out of here.
And that's the sort of thing.
STEFANIE TELLEX: I kind of
made different decisions
about that over my career.
So when I was a post-doc
at MIT, I really,
really, really worked
to avoid soldering time.
I was fortunate.
I kind of walked around.
There's all these great
robot robotic systems.
And I would bolt language
on, and get one paper.
And bolt language on another
way and get another paper.
And you look to get
a faculty position,
you have to have this
focused research agenda.
And so I was focused on that.
And it worked.
I think it was a very
productive time for me.
But I really valued the
past two years at Brown,
where there's not as much
other roboticists around there.
So I've really been forced to
broaden myself as a roboticist
and spend a lot
more time soldering,
making this system for
pick and place on Baxter.
The first year I
didn't hack at all,
and the second year
I started hacking
on that system, the
one that was doing
the grasping with my student.
It was the best
decision I ever made.
I learned so much
about the abstractions.
Because the problems
that we needed
to solve at the beginning,
before I started hacking,
I just didn't understand.
The problems I thought
we needed to solve
were not the problems
that we actually
needed to solve to make the
robot do something useful.
And I don't think
there's any way
we could have gotten to that
knowledge without hacking
and trying to build it.
GIORGIO METTA: In
our case, we've
been lucky, in a
sense, that we had
resources in terms of engineers
that could do the soldering.
So at the moment we still
have about 25 people that
are just doing the soldering.
So it's just a large number.
Yeah.
PATRICK WINSTON: That would
look like a battalion, something
like that.
JOHN LEONARD: Can I say
something more generally?
So there's a lot of claims
in the media and sort
of hyped fears about robots
that take over the world,
or sort of very strong AI.
And partly, they sometimes
they point to Moore's law
as this evidence
of great progress.
But I would say that
in robotics we're
lacking high-performance
commodity robot
hardware that lets us
make tremendous progress.
And so things like Baxter are
great because they're cheap
and they're safe, and they're
a step in that direction.
But I think we're going to
look back 20 years from now
and say, how did we make any
progress with the robots we
had at the time?
Like, we really need better
robots that just get massively
out there in the labs.
RUSS TEDRAKE: But--
TONY PRESCOTT: I was
going to echo that,
because I think robotics is
massively interdisciplinary.
And you've maybe got people more
towards control here slightly.
What we're trying to do
in Sheffield robotics
is actually bringing in more
of the other disciplines
in engineering, but also
science, social science.
Everybody has a potential
contribution to make.
Certainly electronic
engineering,
mechanical engineering.
Soft robotics, I think, depends
very much on new materials,
materials science.
And then these things have
different control challenges.
But sometimes the
control problem
is really simplified if you have
the right material substrates.
So if you can solve
Giorgio's problem, having
a powerful actuator, then
his problem of building iCub
is much simplified.
So I think we have
to think of robotics
as this large,
multi-disciplinary enterprise.
And if we're going to build
robots that are useful,
you have to pull in
all this expertise.
And we're interested in
pulling the expertise
in from social science as well.
Because I think one
of the major problems
that we will face in
AI and in robotics
is kind of backlash, which
is already happening.
Do we really want
these machines?
And how are they going
to change the world?
Understanding what
the impacts will be
and trying to
build in safeguards
against the negative impact is
something we should work on.
PATRICK WINSTON: But Giorgio
had on one of the slides
that one of the reasons
for doing all this was fun.
And I wonder to what degree
that is the motivation?
Because all of you talked about
how difficult the problems are,
and some of them are like
the ones you talked about,
John, watching
that policeman say,
go ahead through the red light.
Those seem not insurmountable,
but very tough and sound
like they would
take five decades.
So is the motivation
largely that it's fun?
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
a big part of it.
I mean, so we've done some
work on steady aerodynamics
and the like, too, and I like--
so we made robotic birds.
And I tried to make robotic
birds like on a perch.
And then we had a
small side project
where we tried to show that
the exact same technology could
help a wind turbine
be more efficient.
PATRICK WINSTON: Yeah
RUSS TEDRAKE: And that's
the important problem.
I could have easily started off
and done some of the same work
by saying I was going to make
wind turbines more efficient.
I was going to
study pitch control.
I'd be very serious about that.
But I did it the
other way around.
I wanted to try to
make a robot bird.
And I think the
win-- not only do
I get excited going
in, try to make a bird
fly for the first time
instead of getting 2% more
efficient on a wind turbine.
I mean, I go in more
excited, but I also--
I get to recruit the
very best students
in the world because of it.
There's just so many
good reasons to do that.
Sometimes it makes me feel a
little shallow because the wind
turbine's way more important
than a robotic bird.
But that is-- the
fun is the choice.
PATRICK WINSTON: What
about it, Giorgio?
Do you do it--
or you have a huge group there.
Somebody must be paid
for all those people.
Are they in expectation of
applications in the near term?
GIORGIO METTA: Sorry.
PATRICK WINSTON: You have
a huge group of people.
GIORGIO METTA: Yeah.
I mean, the group is
mainly funded internally
by IIT, which is public funding
for large groups basically.
And actually, the robotics
program at IIT is even larger--
the group on the
iCub is actually--
there are four
PIs working on it,
and collaborations
with other people
like with the
IIT-MIT group also.
But the overall robotics program
at IIT's about 250 people,
I would say.
So they're certainly
also part of the reason
why we've been able to go
for a complicated platform.
There was one that actually
participated in the DARPA
robotics challenge.
There's people doing quadrupeds
and people doing robotics
for rehabilitation.
So there's various things.
PATRICK WINSTON: So there
must be princes and princesses
of science back there somewhere
who view this as a long-term
investment that will have some--
GIORGIO METTA: It was in
the scientific program
in the Institute to
invest in robotics.
And while one day they may
be looking at the results
and see whether we've
done a good job,
desire to fire us all, whatever.
Hey man, that might be the case.
And I think it was--
unexpectedly IIT
started in 2006.
And the centrifuge
program include
robotics and all the
hype about robotics
that started in recent years,
Google acquiring companies,
this and that, I
think in hindsight
has been a good choice to
be in robotics at that time.
Just by sheer luck, probably.
RUSS TEDRAKE: To
be clear, I think
we're having fun but solving
all the right problems while--
I think we just sort of--
yeah.
We lucked out,
maybe, a little bit.
But we found a way to have fun
and solve the right problems.
So I don't feel that we're--
GIORGIO METTA: I think
it's a combination of fun
and the challenge, so not
solving trivial things
just because it's fun, but
a combination of the two,
seeing something as
an unsolved problem.
STEFANIE TELLEX: So I
try really hard to only
work on things that
are fun and to spend
as little time as possible
on things that are not fun.
And I don't think of
it as a shallow thing.
I think of it as a kind of
resource optimization thing,
because I'm about 1,000
times more productive when
I'm having fun than
when I'm not having fun.
So even if it was more
serious or something,
I would get so much less done
that it's just not worth it.
It's better to do the fun
thing and work the long hours
because it's fun.
So for me it's just-- it's
still obviously the right thing
because so much more gets
done that way, for me.
PATRICK WINSTON: Well, to
put another twist on this,
if you were a DARPA
program manager,
what would you do for the next
round of progress in robotics?
Do have a sense of
what ought to be next?
Or maybe what the flaws in
previous programs have been?
STEFANIE TELLEX: So we've been
talking to a DARPA program
manager about what
they should do next.
And we got a seedling
for a program
to think about planning in
really large state action
spaces to enable--
the sort of middle
part of my talk,
we were talking about
the dime problem, right?
So we wanted a planner
that could find actions
like picking up a like
small scale actions,
but also large scale things
like unload the truck
or clean up the warehouse.
And so we were--
because we thought
that is what's
needed to interpret
natural language commands
and interact with a person
at the level of abstraction.
So we have a seedling
to work on that.
JOHN LEONARD: So if
I could clone myself,
say I made four or
five of my selves.
One of them I would, if I
were DARPA program manager,
to do Google for
the physical world.
So think about having like
an object-based understanding
of things and people in
the environment and places,
and being able to do the
equivalent of internet search,
physical world search,
just combining perception
and then being able
to go get objects.
So the physical-- like, w
get for the physical world.
That's what I would like to do.
TONY PRESCOTT: In
the UK, I think--
so I don't know about DARPA.
But the government made
it one of their eight
great technologies
a few years ago,
robotics and autonomous systems.
And looking again, now, at
the priorities and they're now
looking, well, what are
the disruptive technologies
in robotics, again, is coming
out as one of the things
that they think is important.
So in terms of potential
economic and societal impact,
I think it's huge.
And so if US funding
agencies aren't doing it--
PATRICK WINSTON: What do you
see those applications as being?
TONY PRESCOTT: I think--
well, the big one that interests
me is assistive technology.
In Europe, Japan,
I think the US,
we're faced with
aging society issues.
And I think assistive
robotics in all sorts of ways
are going to be--
PATRICK WINSTON: So you
mean for home health care
type of applications?
TONY PRESCOTT:
Home health care--
prosthetics is already
a massive growth area.
But robots-- I
mean, my generation,
I've looked at the statistics
and the number of people that
are going to be in
the age group 80 plus
is going to be 50% higher
when I reach that age.
And it's a huge burden on
younger people to care for us.
So I think independence in my
own age, I think in my old age
I would love to be
supported by technology.
You can do what you
like with a computer,
but you can't physically
help somebody.
And that's where
robots are different.
So that would be one of
the things that excites me,
and one of the reasons I'm
interested in applications.
I'm driven, I think, by the
excitement of the research
and building stuff.
But I'm also motivated
by the potential benefits
of the applications we can make.
PATRICK WINSTON: I suppose
if they're good enough,
we won't need
dishwashers because they
can do the dishes themselves.
OK.
So now we have a question
from the audience,
which if I may paraphrase,
there have been a--
have there been examples--
I know you think of
them all the time, Tony.
But have there
been examples where
work on robotics in your
respective activities
have shed new light on
a biological problem
or inspired a
biological inquiry that
wouldn't have happened without
the kind of stuff you do?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I started off
more as a biologist, I guess.
I was in a computational
neuroscience
lab with Sebastian Seung.
I tried to study a lot
about how the brain works,
how the motor system
works, in the hopes
that it would help me
make better robots.
PATRICK WINSTON: Oh,
maybe pause there.
Did it?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, it didn't.
So I don't use that
stuff right now.
I mean, maybe one day again.
But our hardware
is very different,
our computational hardware
is very different right now.
I think there's sort of a race
to understand intelligence,
and maybe we'll converge
again right now.
But the things I write
down for the robots today
don't look anything like
what I think the brain--
what I was learning about
what the brain did back then.
But that doesn't mean there's
not tons of cross-pollination.
So we have a great project with
a biologist at Harvard, Andy
Biewener.
Andy has been studying
maneuvering flight in birds.
He's instrumenting birds
flying through dense obstacles.
We're trying to make UAVs
fly through dense obstacles.
We're exchanging
capabilities and ideas
and going back and forth.
Just the algorithms
that we have written
helps him understand what
birds are doing and vice versa.
So there's tons of exchanges.
But the code that I write to
power of the robots today,
I think, is not quite
what the brain is doing,
and nor should it be.
PATRICK WINSTON: Any
other thoughts on that?
GIORGIO METTA: Well,
we have experiments
that I meant to
actually present today,
where we've been working with
neuroscientists on trying
to bring some of the principles
from neuroscience to the robot
construction.
Let's say, not the physical
robot, but the software.
And I find always difficult to
find the level of abstraction
that actually motivate
something from neuroscience
and manages to show something
important for computation.
I think I only have one
example, or two maybe overall.
And it always happen not copying
in details brain structure,
but just taking an
idea what information
may be relevant
for a certain task
and trying to
figure out solutions
that use that information.
In particular, a couple
of things we've done
had to do with the involvement
of motor controlling
information in perception.
And that's something
the sort of paid off,
at least in the
smallest experiments.
Still, we can't compare
with full-blown systems.
Like we've done experiments
in speech perception
and that show to be
over-performing systems
that don't use
motor information,
but on limited settings.
We don't know if we build
the full speech recognition
system what happens, whether
we better or worse existing
commercial methods or
commercial systems.
So it's still a long
way to actually show
that we managed to get
something from the biological
counter-part.
Although maybe for
the neuroscientists
this explains something.
Because where they didn't
have a specific theory,
at least we showed
the advantages
of that particular
solution, that it's
being used by the brain.
TONY PRESCOTT: So
I think there's--
we tend to forget in our history
where our ideas came from.
So for instance,
reinforcement learning--
Demis Hassabis
explained last night
how he's using this
to play Atari computer
games and these amazing
system he's developing.
If you go back in the history
of reinforcement learning,
the key idea there came
from two psychologists,
Rescorla Wagner
developing a theory
of classical conditioning.
And then that got picked up in
machine learning in the 1980s,
and it got really developed
and hugely accelerated.
But then there was crossover
back into neuroscience
with dopamine theory and so on.
And ideas about hierarchical
reinforcement learning
have been developed that
are partly brain inspired.
So I think it's--
there is crossover,
and sometimes we
may lose track of how
much crossover there is.
PATRICK WINSTON: I have another
comment from the audience,
I see we are under some
pressure to not drone on
for the rest of the evening.
So the comment is I think
relevant to the last topic I
wanted to bring up, which
is the question of ethics
in all of this.
And the comment is
why should we make
robots that are good
at operating, doing
things in the household,
take care of the elderly
and so on, when the rest
of AI is going hell-bent
to put a lot of people
out of work and people
who could perhaps
use those jobs.
But in any event, there's
been a lot of concern,
perhaps spawned by some of
the films like Ex Machina
and so on, that
robots will take over.
And I don't think are going
to take over in that sense
very soon.
But do you see--
do you worry-- do you think
about any dangers of the kinds
of technology you're
working on in terms
of economic dislocation
or battlefield robots
or anything of that
sort that might
come about as a
consequence of what you do?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think
it's inevitable.
I think we shouldn't
fear it, but we
have to be conscious of it.
So I mean, would you
look back to the 1980s
and avoid the invent of
the personal computer
because it was going to change
the way people had to do work?
I mean, of course you wouldn't.
But at the same time
that changed the way
people had to do work.
And it was painful for a big
portion of the population,
but ultimately it
was good for society.
I think robots will have
the same sort of effect.
It's going to raise
the bar on what
people are capable of doing.
It's going to raise the
bar on what people have
to be successful in their jobs.
And it might be
painful, but I think
it's super important for
society to keep moving on it.
PATRICK WINSTON: Why, again,
is it super important?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Because
it's going to advance what
we're capable of as a society.
It's going to make us
ultimately more productive.
PATRICK WINSTON: Other thoughts?
TONY PRESCOTT: I agree.
I mean, I think the people that
are worrying about jobs being
taken by robots
aren't the people that
want to do those jobs.
Because most of the
jobs are ones that it's
very hard to get anyone to do.
They're low paid,
they're unpleasant.
And we're automating the
dull and dreary aspects
of human existence.
And that gives the
opportunity for people
to have more fulfilling lives.
Now, the problem
isn't that we're
doing this great work to
get robots or machines
to do these things for us.
It's that, as a
society, we're not
thinking about how
we adjust to that,
how we make sure people
will have fulfilling lives
and will be supported materially
to enjoy that prosperity.
So I think it's
disruptive in many ways,
and it's going to be
disruptive politically.
And we're going
to have to adapt.
Because if you're
not working, then you
have to be supported
to enjoy your life.
And maybe that means a change
in the political system.
So those are questions
perhaps not for us.
But I think we maybe--
as the technologists,
we have to be prepared
to admit that what we're working
on are really disrupted systems
and they are going to
have these large impacts.
And people are
waking up to that.
And if we wave our hands
and say, don't worry,
I think we're not going
to be taken seriously.
PATRICK WINSTON: Other thoughts?
JOHN LEONARD: I see how these
are really important questions.
And I see--
I have mixed emotions.
I'm really torn.
I came from a family
that was affected
by unemployment in the 1970s.
So I feel like I'm very
sympathetic to the potential
for losing jobs.
At CSAIL we've had this
wonderful discussion
with some economists at
MIT the last few years,
Frank Levy, David Autor, and
Eric Brynjolfsson, Andy McAfee,
and I've learned
a lot from them.
And I think that they
vary in their views.
I think I am more along
the lines of someone
like David Autor,
who's an economist who
thinks that we
shouldn't fear too
rapid a replacement of robots.
If you look at the data,
that the things that are--
I would say the things that are
hard for robots are still hard.
But on the other hand,
I think, longer term, we
do have to be mindful of
as a society, that like,
as Russ said, things like
this are going to happen.
I think that the short term
introduction, if you look at,
for example, Kiva and how
they they've changed the way
a warehouse works.
I think replacing humans
just completely with robots,
like, say, for gardening
or agriculture, some really
hard things to do, because
the problems are so hard.
But if you rethink the task to
have humans and robots working
together, Kiva's a good
example of how you actually
can change things.
And so that's where I
think the short term is
going to come from, is humans
and robots working together.
That's why I think HRI is
such an important topic.
PATRICK WINSTON:
Well I don't know
if you running for president,
but be that is it may,
do any of you have
a one-minute closing
statement you like to make?
JOHN LEONARD: Well I'll go sort
of the deep learning thing.
I think in robotics we have
this, potentially, a coming
divide between the
folks that believe more
in that data-driven learning
methods and more models.
And I'm a believer more
on the model-based side,
that we don't have enough
data and enough systems.
But I do fear that we
could be in a society--
for certain classes of problems,
he or she who has the data
may win, in terms of if
Google or Facebook have
just such massive amounts
of data for certain problems
that academics can't compete.
So I do feel there's a place
for the professor and the seven
grad students and a
couple of post-docs.
But if you do you
have to be careful
in terms of problem
selection, that you're not
going right up against the sort
of one of these data machine
companies.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I was
going to say that I
was looking at humans
right now and trying
to inform the robots,
I wouldn't look
at center-out reaching
movements or nominal walking
or things like this.
I'd be pushing for
the corner cases.
I've been trying to
really understand
the performance of
biological intelligence
in the screw cases, in the
cases where they didn't
have a lot of prior data.
They were once in a
lifetime experiences.
How did natural
intelligence respond?
That's, I think,
a grand challenge
for us on the computational
intelligence side.
And maybe there's
a lot to learn.
PATRICK WINSTON: And
the grand challenge
for me, to conclude
all this, has
to do with what it would really
take to make a robot humanoid.
And I've been thinking
a lot about that
recently in connection
with self-awareness,
understanding the story,
having the robot understand
the story of what's going
on throughout the day,
having it able to use
previous experiences to guide
its future
experiences, and so on.
So there's a lot to be
done, that's for sure.
And I'm sure we'll be working
together as time goes on.
Now I'd just like to
thank the panelists
and conclude the evening.